[موسيقى]
شركه من اكبر شركات الاعلاميه في العالم
وفي كوريا شركه ضخمه جدا نتكلم عن ارباح
السنه الماضيه او يراجعتها بالاحرى وصلت
الى 4.9 مليار دولار تقريبا قارب 48
بالمئه مقارنه الكوريه الان صارت منافس
كبير ايضا للسوق هذا عندهم المانوار واللي
هي قصص المصوره الكوريه من تملك وحده من
اكبر منصات القصص المصوره في العالم وتعرض
عليها اعمال المنوات
توسع عالميه
[موسيقى]
في احد الاعمده الثلاثه الرئيسيه
سويتش اللي من صدر ما يقارب خمس سنوات
ويحقق اعلى ارقام مبيعا من بين جميع اجهزه
الالعاب فعدم وجودهم بشكل قوي في السوق
السعودي هذا يعني شيء نحتاج اننا نغيره
فالاستثمار
ويعطيها الشعور ان فيه اهتمام حقيقي من
اعلى درجات الدوله هنا بسوق العاب الفيديو
هذا الشيء مهم عشان نفتح التواصل معهم
ونحقق الشيء اللي احنا نبغاه وهو تواجدهم
بشكل اكبر ورسمي وملموس اكثر في السوق
السعودي